what's that believe nation today I'm
going to talk about the seven ways why
most people don't become wealthy a lot
of entrepreneurs write in to me leave
comments on the YouTube channel send me
messages and say Evan how do I get more
wealthy what are some of the steps what
are the things I need to avoid doing
because I haven't figured it out yet and
so today I'm going to share the seven
things that are the reasons why you
haven't become wealthy yet
[Music]
number one is you have the wrong mindset
this is super important whether you
believe you can or you can't you're
right there's always two sides of the
coin right the glass is half-empty and
is half-full you're both right whatever
side you come on you're going to be
right how do you look at new problems
the new opportunity you see them as a
problem or you see them as an
opportunity right whenever people come
up with a new business idea you're going
to have some people who will tell you
all the reasons why it can work out and
here's the market that you can go to and
here's how to make it work and you can
have the other people come to you and
say all the reasons why it's not going
to work out all the immediate problems
are going to come in why you're never
going to make it work and the thing is
that both right because with any new
idea there's going to be all these
problems and there's going to be lots of
opportunity as well and so these people
are the ones who are going to get
wealthy these people are going to be the
ones who go and have an impact these
people are the ones that go out and
change the world and these people are
the ones who just never do anything
we're just pessimistic and sit on the
couch and complain and blame other
people for why they're not more success
so which can still you fall into are you
part of a group that believes that
anything is possible that when you see
an opportunity you're positive and
optimistic you can go out and do it or
are you part of the ones who are afraid
and are limiting and complain and blame
other people because the mindset is the
most important thing you get that right
and it's not just saying it it's not
just saying yeah I can do it it's
believing it like this is going to
happen
do you actually believe that you are
worthy do you actually believe that you
are going to become a wealthy successful
person because if you don't you're going
to stay here you're just going to take
of all the reasons why you can't do it
if you're focused on why you can't do it
then you're never going to get there so
fix your mindset
[Music]
number two is a poor environment and by
poor I don't just mean bad by poor I
also mean with wealth like poor like
people have no money
kind of mindset and attitude belief
system look at the people around you
those just look at do they have money
but do they have a rich mindset do they
have an abundant mind so do we have that
positive mindset if you are only around
the people in that last example where we
shared the positive people the people
will see the opportunity and the
negative people who just feel the
problem if you're just hanging around
the people who just see problems all the
time then guess what's going to happen
to you right it's going to be really
hard to be that positive person when you
just run to buy negativity and it's not
just the people in your life it's your
habit it's your routine it's your
environment like I walk into this every
day and I get inspired and I want to
think bigger it forces me to think
bigger and push my comfort zone I think
about Alex who's helping me out of
Toronto dance salsa hi hey there how are
you and his morning routine used to be
wake up and look at some 9gag photos
which I hadn't even heard it before at
9gag was but it's jokes and pranks and
tricks and just things to make me laugh
and he substituted that on his own now
by reading leadership articles because
he wants to be a better leader badly he
wants to lead you know the eight
instructors that we have and the 40 of
the 50 helpers that we have and help
them make a bigger impact he desperately
wants that and so switching that habit
from looking at some jokes to now
developing a leadership mindset change
his environment changes perspective give
some more motivation and courage and
optimism going from that poor mindset to
an abundant positive one and so I
challenge you to look at your habits
look at your routine not just the people
around you and not just blaming them
right blame your parents and blame your
friends and blame blame blame blame
blame what are going to do about it
because there's a lot that you can
control you just going to look at all
the things that it's outside your
control all these people around you
great seek out new people go to events
where your kind of people are hanging
out watch videos where you're surrounded
by these people that fill up your head
read books that motivate and inspire you
look at every single habit that you have
and ask yourself the things that you
were doing is it from a poor mindset
it's just making you poor keeping you
where you are or is it feeling you up
and making you richer and wealthier and
not just in a financial sense as a
person you are what you consistently do
so what are you consistently doing if
somebody is healthy they can have a
chocolate bar they can take a nosh down
on an O Henry or Reese's Pieces once in
a while it's not going to impact them
not going to be a huge negative spike
for them but if you're eating chocolate
bars every single day five times a day
you're going to be unhealthy and if
you're doing that every day and you have
one good day and you fall back to your
pattern you're going to stay unhealthy
you are what you consistently do so what
are you consistently doing and how can
you tweak those habits to escape the
poor mindset and have a wealthy one
[Music]
number three is the lack of action so
it's great to have amazing ideas for
what you want to do write amazing ideas
for things that could happen and then
what ends up happening are you actually
taking the action or are you just seeing
other people go out and make lots of
money and have a big impact off of your
idea you can't blame them you can only
blame yourself if you have an idea to
try and do something that you think is
going to have an impact that will make
you wealthy in every sense of the word
then you got to go and do it because a
lot of people are so afraid that their
idea just dies within them the idea dies
with them you had greatness inside you
to go and have a huge impact be
legendary
have your grandkids look up to you as
one of the most influential people in
their lives and you failed everybody
because you just kept it in here because
you were too afraid to go and do
something people don't become wealthy
because they don't act on their great
idea you got to act and again
consistently act you are what you
consistently do so are you consistently
acting every single day to move that
idea a little bit further forward or do
you get a little bit of negativity and
then you stop and you quit when you come
back a little bit and then you quit
again consistency you need to be
prolific be prolific in the pursuit of
your goal daily action don't stop recent
number four why you are not becoming
wealthy is you're trying to do
everything yourself the most successful
people the wealthiest people understand
that other people are a great resource
for them and this is one of the biggest
mistakes I made early on in my first
company I was trying to do everything
myself and so understanding that whether
you you know can afford to bring
somebody on or not is an option like the
first guy I hired was for one hour a day
where I didn't have the budget to go to
have a full time salary for somebody it
was one hour days I freed up my time to
go do more work higher leverage work
work I enjoyed more but also getting
other people involved even on a
volunteer basis right friends family
people that you've met you know when I
first started my youtube channel I made
a deal with a friend of mine mark Drager
from France and media who's actually in
the book is one word is extraordinary
and he came in and shot some videos out
of my office at the time and that's how
I started my youtube channel my future
videos some of them I borrowed cameras
from my friends right like just not just
locking yourself in your own world and
expecting to do everything yourself and
involving more people understanding what
it is that you are great at that you
have Michael Jordan level genius talent
at what is that and spending as much
time there as possible
and eliminate a lot of the other words
and trying to get other people involved
to cover your weaknesses because what
ends up happening the poor mindset is
I'm going to do everything myself and
I'm going to spend 2% of my time on the
genius level talented I'm the best in
the world that I'm 90% 98% of my time
doing the crack doing the work that I'm
not great at that has to get done
because I feel like I got to do it all
myself and so it's being resourceful you
might think yeah that's great if I had a
bunch of money I would go out and hire
people and it would get it done you're
missing the point if that's what you're
thinking
you're already starting with the poor
mindset you're missing the point
it's not about going out to get the
money to hire the people it's about
being resourceful and finding ways that
you can get those people to help you
with you giving them something back that
doesn't have to be monetary they may
help you just because they want to be
around you because they like you they
want to support what you're doing they
may help you because they love the
mission that you're on and they want to
be a part of it you know I try to dance
also we've got 50 people who volunteered
who helped we're higher level students
and come to the lower level classes to
give their advice and experience they do
it for free because they want to get
back because we create a great
environment for them to give back and so
there's people who would want to help
you if you just expand your thinking to
figure out where do I need help and who
can I ask for it you can't do this alone
[Music]
number five is you don't model success
and again I had this problem when I
first started my business I feel like I
had to go with all the ideas myself I
feel like everything that we did every
new execution had to come from within
here and it almost sunk our business it
made me say I quit to my partner and I
came back the next day and I didn't quit
because it was too important to me to
continue but the thing that broke
through that helped my company take off
was me realizing that I'm not the first
guy to try to do this somebody else has
already figured out the model and in
software was industry I was in I look to
Bill Gates
now I sold biotech software Bill Gates
is first software product wasn't biotech
but I could still learn how he made it
work for him and apply to my business
that was the start of the change that
was getting us to the next step and so
whatever problem you've had whatever
problem you're facing right now
somebody's already solved it many people
have already solved it and so looking to
their success understanding what they
did to solve it and applying it to your
business will dramatically improve the
chance of you becoming successful and
wealthy every sense of the word so it's
great to come up with ideas yourself I'm
not saying just copy everybody else it's
great to add your own creativity but you
don't need to come up with every single
idea yourself research who has done it
learn from them apply their strategies
to make your business a success and it
will be number six is you don't provide
enough value this is just the basics of
business if you want to make money money
is only an exchange of value right if
you want to have an impact right it's
going to come from exchanging value so
does your product or service actually
provide enough value to your customer
and I wouldn't blame your marketing or
blame something else it's outside your
control you have the control as Toronto
dance salsa a lot of our business comes
from word of mouth marketing because we
provide a great product a great
experience that people really enjoy and
they want to tell their friends about it
in this business and looking at the
YouTube videos as an example the videos
are good right I get traffic I get an
audience we have half a million plus
subscribers that's great and I deserve
that but I also don't deserve to be at 2
million subscribers because my videos
aren't good enough yet so I'm not
providing you with enough value I'm not
providing you with enough value that you
are off instantly sharing this video
somewhere you are some of you take my
video and you tweet it out you know link
it up on Instagram and you tell all your
friends about it I really appreciate
that but for a lot of you you don't a
lot of you aren't even watching if you
didn't even make it this far and I'm not
blaming you I'm blaming me I got to get
better I gotta take better topics I got
to be right on camera I need to offer
better points need to give you more
tangible advice I need you to get
results from watching
videos if you've got tremendous results
from watching these videos then you
would go off and tell your friends and
my audience would grow a lot faster so I
am offering some value it's how I got
here right it's not that my channel
sucked it's great but it could always be
better and so instead of blaming the
market or blaming economy or blaming the
president or blaming interest rates or
blaming whatever the wealthy successful
entrepreneurs take responsibility they
blame themselves and they look at how
could I do better because it's inside
your control and so you add more value
to the product or service that you're
providing you're going to get better
results and the number seven reason why
most people don't become wealthy is
because they make wealth their only goal
if you look at the people who've had
tremendous success the people behind me
on the wall the people who you can look
up to go to the Forbes list of the
richest people in the world money was
never the number one goal having
financial wealth was never the
number-one goal now it's important money
is important unless you're a charity
which still money is important because
you need money to survive and keep going
and pay for people salaries right money
is important so I'm not saying forget
about money but money is number two
there has to be something above money
for you to keep going because whatever
you get into if you want to be the best
at it if you want to have a lot of
success you don't want to get to that
point where you're providing so much
value that you're the number one person
there's give me a lot of work me a lot
of crap you see a lot of sucking at the
start you don't just coast your way to
number one you work you grind you hustle
your way to number one you put in the
extra practice more than anybody else is
doing you make more videos than anybody
else is doing you work hard in your
craft more than anybody else is doing
this only thing that gets you going is
an absolute passion for the work that
you're doing there has to be something
above money because money is your only
goal you're going to quit as soon as it
gets hard
right money will only keep you going for
so long and then you're going to quit
and so money is your goal you can you
can get there you know you'll make some
money but you're never going to be
really really wealthy you're never going
to get to that point you're never going
to be one of the greatest of all time
because of chasing the wrong thing you
can only force yourself to do something
that you hate for so long before you
quit you'll move on you just you want to
deal with this crap anymore the people
will have success they love the crack
it's not crap for them that's the
difference you would look at my schedule
and what I do on YouTube and think that
is so much I could never do that and
that's why I'm winning and if I looked
at your schedule if I looked at his
schedule his schedule his schedule be
like that's nuts I couldn't do that and
so you have to have the thing that's
above money and understanding what your
one word can help prevent what your
passion is absolutely important monies
number two this is insulting in England
money is number two one of you guys will
do that my name is number two it has to
be something important so that's my take
on the seven reasons why most people's
don't become wealthy I'd love to know
what do you guys think what point
resonated the most with you what can you
take from this video and immediately
apply it to your life your business
did I mention eight nine ten that you
guys want to add to the list leave it
down in the comments below I'm going to
join in the discussion I also want to
give a quick shout out to you all I hope
I pronounced that okay thank you so much
for picking up a copy of my book your
one word and making that picture and
putting me in the seal on the side that
was pretty cool thank you so much for
your love I really appreciate it thank
you guys again for watching I believe in
you I hope you continue to believe in
yourself and whatever you're one where
it is
much love I'll see you soon